you've all finished the game at this
point right right so I've decided to
compile my last 50 secrets for sekito
into one video instead of three because
after this it might be time to move on
let's begin with what might be the best
secret on this list in the shrewder
ending owl orders wolf to forsake his
master with the intent to take Kuro away
from the lands of the Aashna what ensues
is a conflict between Wolf Emma and then
Asian and it's a conflict that owl
excuses himself from just before the
battle but did you ever wonder why our
left here and what he might be doing as
you cut down oisin and Emma
the answer is incredibly subtle but it's
hidden within this scene see if you can
hear it that soft squelching thud is
very suspect it seems like owl is
putting something down right beside
Asians corpse right this led me to ask
Lance McDonald prominent Souls born data
digger disconnect the camera in this
cutscene and see if there was anything
to find and sure enough the thing that
al puts down beside a sheen is the
severed head of Asians grandson Ganesha
so while you were dealing with Emma and
Asian owl stepped away and assassinated
Ganesha toe why well Genichiro is also
competing for kudos blood plus owl also
returns with the black mortal blade
meaning that Ganesha doe must have
located it at this point in the game
black mortal blade in hand very little
should stand in our way
except sure of course who ironically
might have been awakened by the carnage
that owl initiated as that dialogue
reveals Al's real name is Osso II which
links him to a place called Goofy's
forest a mystical place mentioned in two
item descriptions first it's mentioned
in the mist Raven feathers belonging to
one of the many mystical birds that
reside within usui's forest and second
in the phantom kunai item which reveals
that lady butterfly trained
in Al's forest since childhood a place
filled with mist and mystifications
which somewhat explains the shinobi that
al became in our first fight without
he'll recite different parts of the
shinobi code after each death we
experienced at his hand first that the
parent is absolute and if you unlocked a
second resurrection during the fight
by performing a death blow then you hear
that second the master is absolute but
what very few people know is that
there's a third rule one that's never
mentioned unless you unlock a third
resurrection by consuming a Jizo statue
during the fight
three fears absolute there is some shame
in losing one battle but you must take
revenge by any means necessary
no wonder if you've got it in you to
bring me down it's no surprise that owl
is one of Miyazaki's favorite bosses in
sec you know before launch
he gave this interview where he stated
that his favorite boss uses really dirty
underhanded tricks and that they're
devious and that he hopes that we'll
know it when we see it it has to be owl
right for this fight has this fantastic
flavor to it it's a boss that knows how
to disable our heal one that can use
mckiddy
and most impressive to me he's the first
boss that actually has trickery just
built into his animations he starts
feigning attacks just as soon as you get
used to countering them his gameplay
mechanics reflect his character design
which i think is a really worthwhile
design goal for any developer up here as
you know castle is being besieged by the
interior ministry the soundtrack takes a
bit of a turn listen to this part and
tell me if anything sounds familiar
you guessed it that strained sound is
the same one that we heard back in the
10-second shadows die twice teasin in
this same area earlier in the game
we fight Ganesha doe and we see his
second phase here the way of Toma way
but did you ever wonder why he strips
his metal arm off here it could be
because his flesh is astoundingly
resilient anyway thanks to the
rejuvenating settlement it could be that
the way of term away favors flowing
unhindered movement well my favorite
idea is that his metal armor might
conduct electricity and things are about
to get heretic all up in here to prepare
for the invasion warriors of the ocean
of pour over a map within the ash in a
dojo the map depicts the area that
you're in right now here's the main
castle the lake the path to the sunken
valley to the outskirts and back down
the main road just around the corner
from this map is a tiny little shrine on
the wall one that's dedicated to what
can only be the divine dragon its
distinctive face is recognizable as is
the body twisted around the stump of the
sakura tree attached we see what looked
like omikuji little requests for
blessings that are written on paper by
the occupants of the castle and did you
ever wonder how certain shinobi doors
work most of them make sense simply
taking you from one room to the next but
some of them make as much sense as
traveling in Dark Souls 2 from the
earthen peak to the iron keep after
taking an elevator that is to say it
makes no sense to flip a door in a
sheena castle and end up in the
dilapidated temple nor to flip the door
in headless as cave and end up deep
within the mountains of sin po temple
however from his foot one tiny little
detail here to deter any naysayers there
are nine unintelligible ancient Japanese
symbols on the ground in both of these
places which we can only surmise to be
magic markings controlling these shinobi
doors allowing us to teleport from
place to another and as you all know if
it's magic
it ain't gotta explain [ __ ] right
besides some of the smallest most
impressive details often lie the most
egregious mistakes that no law master
wants to bother trying to explain for
example the so-called secret path out of
our China doesn't really deliver
considering it's just an open field with
a broken bridge going nowhere I'm not
exactly sure why secular and Kudo keep
coming back here however in this very
same area we also see some of the best
hidden details that this game has to
offer in our first fight with Ganesha
ROH wolf is fighting after having
experienced a complete defeat having
only recently lost his will to live thus
he's completely out of practice and his
skills here are really rusty and it's
shown visually in this cutscene actually
look at how sekito actually fumbles for
his sword before he pulls it out compare
this to the secular who fights at the
end of the game look how smoothly he
pulls out his sword and prepares for
combat not only that but this wisp of
grass here actually represents kudo who
has just fallen to the ground behind him
it's something that sekito doesn't even
notice
that's how focused he is on the looming
fight with Guinea Chitto moving from
asana into the depths we encounter our
first Chi Chi Minh Warrior which in
Japanese means the warrior with seven
phases his design lives up to that as he
has a ton of phases all over his armor
and attacks with spirit heads that
inflicts terrif this warrior in
particular drops the ceremonial tanto
which is a dagger that was used in
ritual offerings to the divine dragon
they would cut spirit emblems from their
own flesh and as we know spirit emblems
Harbor the souls of the dead considering
this warrior harbors many lost souls
himself it's an item and a task that
really suits this warrior curiously
their armor also features reared up
centipedes on the shoulder guards the
centipedes are representative of the
depraved immortality of the fountain
dead waters so it does make some sense
that these warriors who
once made blood offerings to those
waters would seek to adorn their armor
with their likeness
in fact most characters with centipedes
can trace their immortality to the
fountain headwaters take the guardian
ape for example who in addition to
lurking in a location where the fountain
headwaters pull deeply also soothes its
severed head wound in a small waterfall
of flowing with these same Fountainhead
waters and as the centipede erupts from
the Apes body take special note of the
way that the Apes movement changes
originally it fights like a beast as its
original self but in the second phase
the centipede actually takes control and
now it fights with writhing centipede
like winding attacks furthermore it
learns how to use a weapon which raises
even more questions about the centipedes
and just how intelligent they really are
the Apes waters are Fountainhead waters
which is a fact that's proven once you
succeed at killing the great carp with
Hara Nagas poisonous bait
during the pot noble quest line once
it's fed return here and you'll find its
corpse proof that somehow a corpse even
as large as this one can end up here
speaking of the depths I always found
this piece of dialogue strange where the
old woman asks whether you'll be cast
out or throw yourself in and as I was
scanning through all the dialogue text
that was data mined for the game I
actually discovered this cut line from
Kuro it reads there exists a great Gorge
into which immortals are cast away into
the underworld
obviously he's talking about the ash in
the depths and we do find many undying
down here some of them victims of
experiments with the rejuvenating waters
speaking of cut content down here
originally there was a different item
you gave to the red priests of mibu
village instead of Dragon's spring sake
it was supposed to be a fresh Innes
mouth liver and this is significant
because the town of Innes mouth is the
setting for H P Lovecraft's shadow over
Innsmouth and in this story members of
the village are turning into horrific
aquatic life forms
which not only bears a ton of similarity
to events in mibu but this is the story
that inspired the fishing hamlets in
blood-borne and there exists even more
overlap with blood-borne fishing village
slugs for example are a part of the
story and environment in mibu just as
they're a huge part of blood-borne
fishing hamlet the basket head also
mentions a hunter named Inoue HECO an
outcast who eats the flesh of beasts and
who uses fire to ward away other
villagers just like the hunters do in
blood-borne I think it's less of an
easter egg and more of yet another
example of from software having common
elements across all their games not to
mention the vermin in blood-borne which
have their own counterparts in sequitos
centipedes there's even a hanging man
cradling something that looks like a
humanity sprite here perhaps he was
killed for holding on to his humanity
which is clearly something that the
other villagers have abandoned one thing
that we never really got to the bottom
of was why maybe lake is filled with the
upturned bodies of the villagers the
most logical reason is that they drowned
this way due to their undying thirst but
a more satisfying explanation lies in
the 1976 Japanese film the inugami 's
which features a murder victim who was
found in a lake in this exact same
upturned pose and if I understand
correctly this is something that has
been referenced in more Japanese media
than just secular since then and we have
the sarcastic Canadian on reddit to
thank for catching this one moving back
up to the mountains and valleys of
Hashanah we look next to an item within
SEM PO temple it's a second bell just
like the one that takes us to the
illusory holes this one is found in the
lower part of symp Oh in the room with
the centipede long neck and you have to
wonder if this was ever meant to serve a
purpose an entry point to a future DLC
perhaps one of the most interesting
items in secular is the contact medicine
a consumable that allows the player to
voluntarily inflict a weak poison upon
themselves so that they can't be
affected by
stronger poisons but it's most
interesting use actually pertains to the
mist Raven prosthetic for once you've
taken the poison allows you to - at any
time since they're always taking damage
and if you look carefully at the contact
medicine you'll discover what's
responsible for your affliction
stemming from the powder crushed into
tiny little bits our wings and abdomens
of what can only be wasps or bees next
is something incredibly cool but also
incredibly unknown if you use the
bestowal ninjutsu on the green lizards
then your blade becomes enhanced with
poisonous properties and the same goes
for blood smoke you conjure a green mist
that will poison anything inside of it
the lizards are so easy to kill that no
one ever thinks to waste ninjutsu on
them but these effects are incredible
and honestly it's actually a huge shame
that these lizards are always placed in
out-of-the-way locations imagine if they
were placed within boss fights for
example and you could actually poison
bosses by taking out a lizard at a key
moment I feel like this ninjutsu could
actually give you an edge in those
fights the same principle applies to the
white lizards of course though the
effect is way harder to figure out after
a ton of experimenting I realized that
the Stowell actually imbues your blade
with a lifesteal effect and that the
blood smoke can be used to conjure a
health regenerating cloud but you'll
never need to heal if you never take
damage and there's no way to take no
damage more stylish than the simple kick
into high monk it actually deals really
fantastic amount of posture damage if
you use it as an anti sweep attack
because it also gets the bonus for
jumping onto an enemy as well just don't
use it when your enemies are equipped
with projectiles as you'll take extra
damage and get smacked out of the air of
course this principle applies to your
enemies as well every time they're in
the air make sure you throw a shuriken
or you can even throw ceramic shards to
knock enemies out of the air this might
be one of the most underrated items in
the whole game speaking of anti-air
death blow
a surprising amount of enemies are
susceptible to them
there's the twin blade enemies the akami
but most useful is actually against the
Shi Sherman Warrior you may not have
realized that you can use this here
though because it only becomes possible
to do if you have divined confetti
active on your weapon confetti is also
an item that's generally underrated
especially in the late game and New
Game+ where you can purchase an infinite
supply after getting the dragon's tally
board from the corrupted monk it's the
best item to spend your sin on at that
point because divine confetti actually
increases your weapon damage against all
enemies not just apparitions this item
allows you to connect with apparition
type enemies because the paper is
created using water from The
Fountainhead and its blessed by the gods
and this got me thinking well then how
come you can damage the headless
underwater without the confetti then one
answer might be that since they're
underwater in the same divine waters
that created the divine confetti they
might naturally be vulnerable to it as a
result moving on down into the valley
you encounter this League of snipers who
can take you out at an insane distance
and what I love in this area is just the
attention to detail even with the
whipping winds these snipers are still
able to hit you and the reason is these
these I think are called wind socks
which allow you to tell which direction
wind is blowing and how fast all at a
glance this is an invaluable tool for
the snipers of the sunken valley to him
those snipers sound pretty opie right
well what if I told you that you could
recruit one of them for your own I found
this idea on YouTube and it's pretty
genius you just use puppeteer on the
snake eyes right outside the guardian
ape fog gate and you can actually bring
her in with you as ranged support during
this difficult to v2 fight just make
sure you reapply the effect throughout
the fight and the fight against the two
Apes actually ends up being much more
fair something people rarely do is kill
the guardian ape before you kill the
Guardian ape slow
health mate if you do this then you
actually don't need to even kill the
mate she just gets sad and leaves
instead this next theory was put forward
by a Japanese blogger there's a
translated link in the description
it puts forward that years ago a Sheena
might have been hit by a meteorite made
of Adamantite which would explain the
precious metal scraps that Ashima is
known for as well as this deep lake
that's right in the middle of the
fountainhead to add to this I would put
forward that laser light the rare metal
of Fountainhead palace also would have
come from this meteorite as well because
the last line of the laser light
shuriken actually reads the laser light
blue trail of light it emits in flight
is reminiscent the shooting star this
meteor would explain a few things it
would explain why the metals of the
asana are so special so special that
they attracted the attention of the gods
it would explain the supernatural powers
of the divine waters and perhaps most
importantly it would explain why the
mibu breathing technique was required to
meet the divine dragon the path to the
palace is underwater after all but it
can't have always been this way the
crater must have filled with water after
the arrival of the divine dragon right
before meeting the divine dragon we find
what is surely a Miko a sort of female
shaman or shrine Maiden and if my
research is correct then their role was
one of spirit possession and cleansing
and she may have even served as a means
of communication with the divine
allowing the dragon to possess and speak
through her you can make a very strong
case for both mortal blades originating
from the divine realm the open gate or
black mortal blade has a description
that asks the user to make offerings to
the dragon's blood and the gracious gift
of Tears or red mortal blade was surely
intended for use on the divine dragon
because it gets its tears though it's
impossible to know why it was created if
you look at the box it comes from
actually you can even see the same crest
commonly found in Fountainhead palace
furthermore the red mortal blade was
taken and hidden by the simple high
priest the man who founded semper temple
meaning that the man himself surely once
traveled to this palace a fact that
makes sense when you look at the
similarity in architecture between these
two places that's what I love about From
Software's games their world building is
just so consistent and it's beyond
compare while exploring the fountainhead
it's easy to become enfeebled likely
leading to a quick death as you can't
even resurrect in this state however you
can still fight back barely and if you
manage to inflict a death blow upon an
opponent you actually undergo a unique
kill animation in your weakened state
while recording this death blow I
managed to get a closer look at one of
the crests on the palace noble scarves
it's a picture of the Vermilion bird
something that's mentioned a couple more
times in game nearby is the Vermillion
bridge where you fight the corrupted
monk and it's also emblazoned upon
suzaku's Lotus umbrella which protects
you from flame but what exactly is the
Vermilion bird well put simply it's
basically the eastern version of the
Phoenix it's a red pheasant that is
perpetually covered in flame a
mythological spirit creature of the
Chinese constellations another cultural
reference nearby is the mask that's worn
by the corrupted monk specifically this
is actually called a Hannya mask
something that's used to represent a
jealous female demon in Japanese noir
theater it has a wonderful design
because when you look at it straight on
it's meant to look frightening and angry
but when you look at it from an above
angle the face is sorrowful and it's a
design that's intended to convey the
complexities of human emotion another
cultural reference is the great carp
which could pertain to the Chinese
legend of the Dragons gate as the story
goes many carp a swim upstream in the
rivers
but very few are brave enough to make
that final leap over the waterfall to
the Dragon's Gate if a cop successfully
makes the jump it can transform into a
powerful dragon and considering the
divine dragon is actually called the
ninja dragon in cut content and the word
Nino describes a sort of carp we can put
stock in this legend as it relates to
the divine dragon and speaking of the
carp did you know that it's possible to
make it friendly if you feed him core
Amore's truly precious bait then he'll
no longer attack you in the underwater
stealth section another beast in the
fountainhead palace is the Sakura bull
roaming at the back of the area since
this isn't actually a boss fight like
the other bull fight you can use the
Firecracker from stealth here which
scares the bull to death literally while
all this is going on below I also want
to point out that the alchemy on the
rooftops are just chillin and enjoying
their sake anyway back to the bull
scaring it completely breaks the bulls
posture something that can never happen
to you as long as you deflect the attack
sure your posture backhand fill even
when you deflect perfectly some attacks
are just too powerful but as long as you
deflect them nothing will ever actually
break your posture meter a fact that is
particularly important in new game+ and
that's something I've never actually
mentioned on the channel new game+
brings with it the option to give back
kudos charm an item that he slips on to
your person at the start of the game
without it you actually take about 30%
chip damage
whenever you block against attacks so
playing in this way requires you to
deflect perfectly if you want to get by
another item you might have taken for
granted is the hidden tooth or the bite
down drunk both of which grant you death
however it's not a regular sort of death
usually when you die your resurrections
are afflicted by a black strike through
which prevents you from resurrecting for
a time however if you commit sudoku with
this item you actually get no such black
strike meaning that a player
who accepts their death with a little
bit of foresight can actually squeeze
out more resurrections especially if you
have extra resurrections granted by the
Sakura droplet that drops from Lady
butterfly speaking of death it was
originally planned that NPCs with dragon
rot could die a mechanic that thankfully
never made it into the game this was
discovered again by Lance McDonald whose
video on the topic you can find in the
description and he talks about how they
used to be an item called dragon rot
pellets which you could create via EMA
by trading in some of your resurrected
power giving these pellets to a sick NPC
would heal them but just imagine how
tedious this would have been compared to
the cure-all item we have in the
dragon's blood droplet another great
asset to the community is named illusory
warm who always discovers really neat
things about these games long ago he
discovered that if you spam buttons
while you're grabbed you'll take
significantly less damage one more
mechanic that did make it into the game
but that not many know about is a method
by which you increase your stealth when
you fall from a high place crouch as
soon as you hit the ground and you'll be
able to better stealth past enemies like
this one even from above
speaking of above the award for the
highest kill goes to evil plan Z on
reddit who says [ __ ] this monkey in
particular my final fact pertains to the
secular design works which is this book
of gorgeous art that you can pick up
pretty easily online from sites like yes
Asia and Amazon links are in the
description go check it out it's an
amazing collector's item but there
aren't too many revelations in here
compared to previous design works except
for one interesting piece of what must
be cut content which depicts what
appears to be Emma horizon band and her
hair is graying in the same manner that
ours
kuroh and the Okami saw thank you as
always for watching back in March when
secular released I first promoted demon
VII TV
my first piece of much and you guys
really liked it
so now as we wind down secular content
I'm doing a limited edition sunset
version where Vaati is equipped with a
katana you can only purchase this in the
next 48 hours and from then on you'll be
the only ones who own it so if you like
the content I make and more importantly
if you like the design then go and check
it out in the description below it's
really hardening to have you all still
supporting what I do so thank you so
much and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you